you know I got to ask you this because
she was a good friend of mine Carrie
Fisher and you know you got to work with
her and fanboys
love her she was she was she just get
mad at me because I said God you let my
grandma and she's like [__] you and I go
no no no no I mean like your house is
always open you're like hey stop by in
between auditions have a sandwich in the
fridge going do whatever I don't have to
be home I stayed at her house for four
months and went up for bungalows because
I was going through a rough time and uh
it was it was just insane she's so
giving so wonderful and it was a real
loss it was a real loss but what was
your experience I don't know how long
you got to work with her but what was it
like for you she was on set
or a day she was the nurse in that scene
um and I just you know it was a it was a
sad scene where she because our friend
um
uh Chris Marquette Linus
he's dying and he's not feeling well and
she's like supposed to come out and just
be like he's he can see you now you know
right and I'm just sitting there just
like like staring at her oh my God
right right I'm supposed to be sad
and I couldn't get the [__] smile off
my face
she is a trip dude
she
um
this is how I'll always always remember
her
where
we're also we all came back from a break
and we're sitting around in the waiting
room where she's supposed to come in and
tell us to come and meet with Linus and
we're like we're waiting on Carrie and
we're like okay yeah where's Carrie and
she's just all I'm here
if we looked down and she's just like
took her break on the floor
just like lying on the floor
eating eating fruit loops off of her
chest
and she's like hey guys
it's like
you know Jesus so relaxed and just like
you know she's been living on sets her
whole life and
there was just like this I don't know as
we just had so much reverence for her
and then of course I was so jealous that
Marquette got to kiss her you know I was
just like [__]
oh that's amazing you know uh she did an
episode of Smallville and oh yeah uh
they were looking for her too they were
looking for Carrie and they found her in
the you know those giant air
conditioning vents that they put on set
the little like worm-like things that
are really big that blow cold air into
the she was she was in one cooling off
yeah he was living in there
yeah she likes to get into a little Nook
oh miss your rest in peace Yeah man so
honored that I got to meet her got to
meet Billy D on on uh Fanboys yeah
um got to meet some a lot of my favorite
people like I love Star Wars we can talk
about that a whole a whole episode we
could talk about Star Wars
you know it's funny care I've talked
about this but she gave me her Force
awakens chair
oh Carrie Fisher uh yeah it was how did
you become such good friends with her
what was that my I had an assistant at
the time and she called her assistant
called my assistant and said hey this is
Carrie Fisher's assistant and Kerry's
daughter is a big fan of Smallville and
Carrie wants to know if you could send
her an autograph and I go uh could she
send me a Return of the Jedi autograph
when she's almost naked with Jabba the
Hutt and so I still have the picture it
says Blow Me Carrie
and we became friends and she'd invite
me to her parties we actually threw a
party together
um and uh I just started hanging out
with her and going I I again I've always
had this feeling my my listeners know
that I never really felt like I belong
when I'm around big celebrities and
things but I'd go to this these
gatherings and it'd be Carrie Fisher uh
Harrison Ford uh you know uh Robert
Downey Jr
um uh Nicole Kidman and like you know 15
people hanging at her house all the time
like Meryl Streep and like Michael get
in here say hello I'm like
hey Meryl Streep hey George Lucas hey
she didn't give a [__] she was like this
is my friend this is Michael I don't
care how big stars you are he's welcome
and she always made you feel like that
and we just hit it off she knew I came
from a dysfunctional family and
obviously she did too and uh you know
Debbie Reynolds lived in in front of her
in the little her little house that in
on the same property right so we'd go
down and visit Debbie who's watching QVC
till three in the morning and she'd have
all these pictures of like all these big
stars saying to Debbie I love you and
it's Frank Sinatra and just crazy [__]
man so that's how we became friends